capa du mak d'éthique voilà un
particulier sarkozy pour lequel j'avais
beaucoup d'estimé et bien il va
extraordinairement déçu pourquoi
pourquoi
ne pas savoir sur quel pied danser et
puis et puis il va picorer dans les
mains de
deux bâtons et puis l'arrivée comme
arriviste on fait pas mieux et
franchement
c'est de l'année catastrophe ces gens là
j'espère qu'il est arrivé c'est un
arriviste et qui sera arrêté au volant
sarkozy aurait même été invité ici
aujourd'hui midi l'a repoussé
l'invitation vous le regrettez qui
souhaitait pas ça va me voilà que
j'avais les bras je pourrais il faut les
gagner
je vis valérie les taxes forlin le
chemin
il se repose il est battu trop ces mêmes
devoirs j'ai pas pensé
la merde
toutes ces casseroles et puis et puis la
libye
en chemin
[Applaudissements]
on veut des êtres sans merci
[Musique]